لغه التهديد والوعيد يتردد صداها في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه
الغاضبه من التحالف الامريكي الكوري
الجنوبي لا تفتح توجه رسائلها الصاروخيه
هذه المره يصمت الزعيم لتتحدث شقيقته
كينيو جونغ فتنطق المراه صاحبه النفوذ
القوي بما ينطق به كيم جونغ اون بل ان
كلماتها بدت اكثر حزما وجراه قالت كيميو
ان اي تحرك عسكري لاسقاط احد صواريخ
التجارب الكوريه الشماليه سيكون بمثابه
اعلان حرب كما حذرت من ان بلادها قادره
على اطلاق مزيد من الصواريخ على اهداف في
المحيط الهادي مضيفه ان تلك المياه لا
تخضع لسياده الولايات المتحده ولا اليابان
رغم ان التجارب للصواريخ البالستيه يحضرها
مجلس الامن الدولي الا ان الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها لم يجازف مطلقا محاوله
اعتراضها وهو ما يعزز في راي مراقبين
مساعي الدوله المعزوله والمدججه بمختلف
الاسلحه لتحويل المحيط الهادي الى ميدان
رمايه يمكنها من تطوير قدراتها العسكريه
في المقابل تستعد قواتنا امريكيه وكوريه
جنوبيه لاجراء مناورات عسكريه مشتركه
واسعه النطاق وعلى مدى عشره ايام قبل ذلك
اجرى الطائرات الحربيه الامريكيه بينها
القاذفه الاستراتيجيه ب 52 تدريبات سريعه
الثلاثاء مع طائرات جنوبيه مقاتله ردا على
ما سمته سول تهديدات كوريا الشماليه
بتدمير مهابط الطائرات
ترتيبات تصر واشنطن وحليفتها الجنوبيه على
انها ذات الطابع الدفاعي بينما تعتبرها
بيونكيان استعراضا للقوه وتصعيدا متعمدا
للتوتر بل وتمرينا على غزو اراضيها
واستهداف نظامها السياسي